Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, guten Morgen Tim.
Ist ja gar nicht morgen.
Du verrätst das immer, ne? Ich hätte das ja jetzt eiskalt durchgehalten, einfach so zu tun, als hätten wir das morgens.
Ah das nehmen die heute uns doch nicht ab. Wir klingen nicht so, als wäre es morgen.
Äh echter äh klingt man anders, also äh weiß ich nicht.
Klar, also deine Stimme, die sonst immer so diesen äh äh schönen Schlafzimmerton hat, so, ja, die ist jetzt schon viel äh so Quirki, ne? Jetzt kommst du schon so ein bisschen mehr wie so ein Clown rüber, finde ich.
Boah also Thema eins so so machen wir das. Clown.
Netz klauen, du. Jetzt jetzt Podcast, dass du nicht mehr mit mir, was?
Hier geht's um ernste Sachen. Das alles Internet.
Weiß. Deswegen muss man ja auch mit Humor einsteigen, damit man danach nicht weint.
Mit dem Clown, mit Linus, dem Clown.
Genau,
So, jetzt haben wir äh ein bisschen unsere äh Sendung verschieben müssen, denn äh ich bin ein wenig auf Reisen diese Woche und jetzt passt's gerade mal. Aber wir sitzen halt heute mal nicht im Studio zusammen, sondern,
machen das über das, dieses Internet, von dem man ja immer mehr hört.
Kein guter Einstieg für das nächste Thema. Das nächste Thema, nee, das nächste Thema ist ein Werbeblog,
Wir möchten die Nutzer darauf hinweisen, dass äh es sich jetzt lohnen wird, bei äh Telekom einen besonderen Tarif zu wählen,
nämlich Spotify mit mit eingebaut hat. Und das ist ja ganz toll, weil ähm Millionen Musikfans aus aller Welt haben sich ja bereits davon überzeugt, dass Spotify ein neuer, aufregender Weg ist, Musik zu genießen, zu entdecken und zu teilen,
Sie erkunden dabei eine der größten Musiksammlungen überhaupt.
Mit der deutschen Telekom als Partner hat Spotify jetzt die Möglichkeit, einen noch größeren Kundenstamm in Deutschland zu erreichen.
Durch den Arzt rufen.
Die exklusive Kooperation mit einer Laufzeit von mindestens einem Jahr stellt für die Telekom einen weiteren Schritt. Im Zuge ihrer innovativen Partnerinnenstrategie da.
Das erste war ein Zitat des äh Spotify äh Sprechers, Managers, Global General Manager Distribution in Partnership, Gerrit Meier,
und der letzte Spruch war irgendwie von einem äh Telekom äh Spezialisten,
wobei Spezialist und Telekom. Also einer von der Telekom. Was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben bei der bei der IFA bekannt gegeben,
dass sie eine Art Mobilfunktarif mit integriertem Spotify-Premium Account anbieten wollen. Für dreißig Euro ab Oktober zwanzig zwölf.
Und ähm Spotify kennen wir ja, ist dieser dieser Musikstreaming Dienst, der äh wenn man also kostenlos ist momentan einem ermöglicht, äh Musik zu hören und wenn man einen Premium-Account hat, kann man das auch auf seinem Mobiltelefon tun.
Und ich glaube heute diesen Premium-Account ist,
außerdem inbegriffen, dass man irgendwie, glaube ich, sogar mehrere tausend Lieder zu temporären offline Nutzung auf sein Mobiltelefon knallen kann. Und,
in dieser Partnerschaft mit der Telekom ist es dann jetzt möglich, Musik zu streamen über das Telekom äh drei G-Netz.
Ohne äh das wohl, ohne dass das dabei anfallende Datenvolumen von dem Datenvolumen, dass man beim Tarif inklusive hat, abgezogen.
Ah, verstehe.
Das heißt, man hat quasi sein Datenvolumen von, was ist das? Vielleicht irgendwie fünfhundert MB bei so einem dreißig Euro Vertrag, viel mehr wird das nicht sein. Äh vielleicht auch nur zweihundert,
aber äh wenn man sich mit Spotify verbindet, dann wird das abgezogen von diesem Tarif,
von diesem Volumen. Das heißt, ich kann so viel Spotify hören, über mein äh Telekom3-G-Netz, wie ich möchte.
Toll. Man kriegt sozusagen was geschenkt.
Ja, kostet, glaube ich, äh wird dann als auch eingeführt werden für weitere äh Online-Tarife bei der also für andere Telekom-Tarife als so eine Option von zehn Euro, aber das kostet der Spotify-Premium-Account glaube ich ohnehin.
Also Spotify jetzt bei der Telekom wunderbar toll, geht nicht vom Datenvolumen ab. Schöne Sache. Das ist genau das, wovor wir immer gewarnt haben.
In puncto Netzneutralität.
In Punkto Netzneutralität, denn was wir da jetzt sehen, ist also, dass äh äh der Traff, also wir haben ja.
Es wird ja jetzt noch nicht von einer Bevorzugung von Traffic gesprochen, aber ähm die, dass diese damit einhergehen wird, ist
ist ja relativ wahrscheinlich, äh wenn Telekom diesen Service vernünftig äh anbieten möchte. Aber es heißt eben auch, dass ein,
Datenpaket, was von Spotify kommt, für meine Abrechnung, eine andere Bedeutung hat als ein Datenpaket,
was von einem anderen Server kommt oder von einem anderen Anbieter und im spannendsten Fall sogar von einem anderen Anbieter, der den gleichen Dienst anbietet,
Nämlich zum Beispiel die Metaebene über Instacast. Da könnt ihr ja auch per Livestreaming die Podcasts hören.
Und in dem Fall wird das dann von eurem, geht das von eurem Volumen ab. Und die Meterebene ist gegenüber Spotify, in diesem Fall jetzt so als einfaches Beispiel benachteiligt. Das heißt, wir haben eine total, also eine,
wunderbare Ausgangssituation zur Bildung von äh Monopolen und Kartellen, wenn sobald wir so etwas als Nutzer dulden, weil natürlich die,
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie's bei Telekom und Spotify ist, wer sich da ähm,
wie viel für diese Dienstleistung bezahlen lässt oder wie die meinen, sich die das Geld teilen zu können, was dabei rumkommt. Ähm also ich,
muss jetzt gerade überlegen, hat jetzt die Spotify, hat jetzt die Telekom, Spotify gekauft oder Spotify, die Telekom.
Tja, man nennt das eine Partnerschaft.
Genau, es ist also Partnerin. Wahrscheinlich machen die einfach äh Hälfte, Hälfte.
So irgendeine Beteiligungsmodell wird's da sicherlich geben so, ne? Das ist äh nicht unerheblich, keine Ahnung, wer da die größeren Konzessionen machen muss, aber in gewisser Hinsicht zahlt ja die Telekom den Traffic,
bisschen runterbricht auf auf die tatsächliche das tatsächliche Versprechen und du kaufst quasi also ich kann ja mal hier, ich weiß nicht, ich will jetzt hier nicht unbedingt den äh,
Teufelsanwalt spielen, aber nur um mal so ein bisschen zu äh rumzustochern, wie man das noch so sehen könnte. Also zunächst einmal handelt es sich aus meiner,
um so eine Art zusätzliche Benutzer äh Entschuldigung Dienst beschränkte Flatrate.
Also ich kaufe quasi nochmal zu meiner sogenannten Flatrate eine richtige Flatrate, darf die aber eben nur mit einem Anbieter nutzen.
So kannst du es aussehen, ja. Also es ist sogar noch viel besser, so wie du es jetzt sagst, ist nämlich heiß, also klingt's eigentlich noch asozialer, weil du hast eine Flatrate nur für einen Anbieter und das rechtliche Internet ist abgeschnitten.
Ja, na gut, das ist nicht abgeschnitten.
Du hast, du hast, du hast Spotify und, und, und ein bisschen Restinternet. Ja, genau, du hast ein bisschen Restinternet.
Bist du sicher, dass da keine zusätzliche Limitierung drin ist und bei Spotify? Also ich meine, was ist jetzt, wenn ich wirklich äh vierundzwanzig sieben Spotify empfange.
Da gibt's sicherlich nochmal irgendeine Einschränkung, aber in dieser Pressemitteilung auf der Telekom Homepage steht äh ganz klar so viel, wie sie wollen oder äh keine weitere Begrenzung äh äh inklusive und so weiter. Ähm.
Ich ich schaue gerade mal ganz kurz.
Zwar ohne dass die Online-Nutzung äh des Spotify-Streamingdienstes gegen das im Tarif enthalte, eine Datenvolumen gerechnet wird. Sicherlich haben die irgendwo eine kleine Begrenzung auf äh so und so viel Stunden oder so.
Ja, ist halt immer die Frage, ob's unbegrenzt ist oder unbegrenzt eins mit so einer kleinen Eins, unten als Fußnote, wo drauf steht, na ja, also ihr wisst schon, wie wir das meinen.
Aber ich will, ich will jetzt nicht, das wird schon so, na ja, sie wissen, sie wissen schon, äh äh Einschränkungen geben. Aber ähm,
Also ich möchte, wie gesagt, nochmal betonen, das ist wirklich, also das ist das Ende dessen, was eben Internet ausmacht, ne.
Die Idee, Internet war, dass das alle da irgendwie ihren Kram hin und her schicken können, dass es unabhängig davon ist, äh wo ich das hinschicke, oder nicht, es gab noch nie so einen Tarif,
mit Akustikkopplern eingewählt, da war es egal wo wir damit hinge äh geballert haben mit Modems war es egal, da haben wir wir haben Minutentarife gehabt,
und ähm wir haben Flatrates gehabt und wir haben Volumentarife gehabt. Das waren immer die Sachen und es war immer Internet, was da am anderen Ende rauskam. Und es gab jetzt erst, gibt jetzt seit Kurzem,
diese Ideen, dass man sagt, ja, du hast hier äh Volumentarif, aber das und das und das darfst du selber machen,
Und da, wie gesagt, was also passieren wird, ist natürlich, dass jetzt weitere Anbieter, die solche Musikstreaming-Dienste machen und es gab ja welche vor Spotify und es wird auch welche nach Spotify geben.
Ähm dass ich sie jetzt namentlich äh gar nicht korrekt benennen kann, zeigt schon, äh welche äh Kraft dieser auf dem Markt entwickeln konnten. Ähm,
Aber es an mit Spotify, wenn sich das durchsetzt, die an denen wird eben keiner mehr vorbeikommen. Und was wir in Zukunft wahrscheinlich sehen werden, also ich denke, was so die die äh die End,
Vision ist, die natürlich Firmen äh im Moment haben. Ist sowas wie, dass du ein ähm.
Eine diese Basisinternetversorgung an, von mir aus, Facebook, Spotify, äh Gmail und solchen Scherzen bekommst.
Und für alles.
Hier Internet, inklusive Flatrate für Twitter und Facebook.
Genau, Twitter, Facebook
so die so die Dienste die du so die großen Dienste die sind da schon drin und dann wird dir gesagt da pass mal auf das hast du hier das ist schon mit drin in deinem Tarif da musst du gar nicht mehr für extra bezahlen. Wenn du jetzt auch noch richtiges also den Rest des Internets haben möchtest,
dann müssten wir jetzt natürlich nochmal hier äh nochmal einen Zehner äh monatlich,
die Folge dessen wird natürlich sein, dass äh Nutzer sagen, naja okay, dann verzichte ich halt dadrauf, ja. Und dann äh habe ich habe, solange ich meinen.
Dem Motto, ich brauche ja nur Facebook.
Solange ich mein Facebook habe, ist alles gut
und ähm das ist natürlich eine relativ düstere Prognose für die Freiheit des Internets, wenn man sich da mal so anschaut, dass sich ohnehin gerade alles in Richtung dieser ähm beschnittenen Mobilgeräte, iPhone, iPad, ähm.
Wie heißen die anderen Android und so bewegt,
dann haben wir da irgendwie von diesem, von diesem spannenden, freien Durcheinander äh innovativen Meinungsfreiheit äh dezentral, Internet irgendwann,
nur noch relativ wenig über, nämlich etwas, was äh an Fernsehen erinnert, ja.
Und wo es wo es man sich dann irgendwann auch einkaufen muss. Ja ähnlich wie bei den Fernsehkanälen, wenn ich sage, ich möchte aber jetzt hier einen Fernsehkanal haben, da muss ich mir erstmal irgendwie da
'ne Frequenz auf so 'n Satelliten kaufen oder so, ne? Um um irgendwie die Fernseh senden zu können. In dem Fall macht das ja sogar noch Sinn, weil es irgendwie 'ne begrenzte.
Begrenzte Ressorts äh begrenzte Anzahl an an Frequenzen auf diesem Satelliten gibt, auf denen ich senden kann. Aber im Internet, das war ja das mal das Revolutionäre am Internet, dass genau das eben nicht der Fall ist.
Man sollte also solche Sachen keinesfalls äh keinesfalls äh solchen Geschäftsmodellen auch noch recht geben.
Weil das äh für uns alle von Nachteil sein wird, ganz offensichtlich.
Gut, wir wir prangern das an und äh finde es nicht gut.
Ich warne da entschieden vor ich sehe ich prangere das nicht nur an, ich ich glaube, das ist der Dammbruch, das ist äh das ist unser das ist der ist das Ende vom Internet, das Ende des Internets.
Gott, das hat jetzt schon angefangen. Hm.
Ja, so schnell geht das. So, jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt. Ja, okay, ich will's gar nicht lächerliche treiben. Ähm die Frage ist, wie man dem.
Wie man dem jetzt begegnet. Begegnet dem denn schon irgendjemand? Hast du schon von irgendeinem, gibt's schon die erste schon die ersten Buttons und Demo-Aufrufe?
Na ja, es gibt äh glaube ich ein paar äh Zeitungsartikel und eine äh Pressemitteilung von äh digitale Gesellschaft, ja. Ähm.
Das Problem, was wir hier sehen, ist eben auch, dass also es es war ja eigentlich.
Ich schaue gerade, ob ich den finde. Ne, mal gucken. Also das das das Problem äh bei diesen Sachen ist ja, dass.
Oder es war klar, dass Netzneutralität uns als Service ähm vorgestellt werden würde.
Äh also die die Netzneutralitätsdebatte wird ja schon seit längerem geführt und es war irgendwie ganz klar, dass man uns das am Ende,
dass man uns kommen würde mit den der Netznetralitätsverletzung als Dienst. Also im Vergleich zu,
wir sperren Skype, wir sperren wir drosseln, betreuen so viel Gig, wir machen, wir verbieten dieses, wir verbieten dieses. War klar, dass man
über die Zusatzdienste kommen würde. Da habe ich schon vor zwei Jahren
mit Leuten von verschiedenen Organisationen in der in der US-Botschaft drüber diskutiert, dass sie meinten, ja, aber die Zusatzdienste und das ist doch alles ganz toll und da wäre man doch beknackt, wenn man da nicht,
also die haben auch relativ offen geredet, deswegen sage ich jetzt nicht, wer das war. Dann sagte, da wäre ich doch bescheuert, wenn ähm wenn ich das Geld, was ich dafür nehmen kann,
nicht abschöpfen würde, ja? Und es war relativ klar so diese diese Zusatzdienste, dass das jetzt das Spannende ist, ja und man irgendwie mal, dass man darüber nachdenkt, ob man nicht vielleicht ähm
den Internetzugang insofern beschränkt, dass eben dass man YouTube HD Videos oder so,
dass man die einfach mal selektiv drosselt und sagt, dafür muss aber extra bezahlen. Und da hast du eben, dann kannst du die Hände aufhalten gegenüber YouTube und gegenüber den Nutzern. Und während die Nutzer sturmlaufen, ist natürlich diese diese Idee.
Ähm dann die, die Inhalte, Anbieter, äh mit denen sich irgendwie zu einigen, und dann eben, ja, irgendwie so eine Art mächtiges,
mächtige Clique zu bilden, die irgendwie dafür sorgt, dass dieses Internet jetzt erstmal, ne, alles, was die Leute da haben wollen, das ist erstmal in unserer Hand. Und da kommt uns auch so schnell kein Nächster hinterher und konkuriert und
das war die große Sorge und das ist jetzt äh sehen wir jetzt im Moment an allen Ecken und Enden unter anderem auch bei der Telekom und Spotify und deswegen ist das.
Es ist eine gefährliche Entwicklung, der mir im Moment wenig einfällt, als ähm so etwas zu verbieten, wie es auch in äh den Niederlanden ähm vor einiger Zeit geschehen ist.
Ja, eine gefährliche Entwicklung scheint ja auch das äh Internet als solches äh äh zu sein. Äh da äh entstehen diverse Bedrohungsszenarien und das hört sich dann in etwa so an.
Ja und insofern, wie gesagt, vielleicht ist das auch gar nicht so schlecht, wenn das äh Internet dann bald weg ist. Äh wenn man sich das so anhört, ja, also vielleicht, vielleicht ist da alles gar nicht so alles richtig, was die.
Ja, wir sollten's kurz äh aufklären, äh worum es sich hierbei gehandelt hat.
Das war Günther Jauch. Am vergangenen Sonntag in seiner Sendung mit dem Titel Hilfe macht das Internet uns dumm oder so.
Ja im Rahmen dieser äh wöchentlichen SadoMaso Sendung, mit dem sich die Deutsche Gesellschaft äh immer wieder hingibt.
Ja, diese Falle nach dem Tatort, ja, das.
Dieser Sonntagabendslot äh scheint ja eher so eine Art Selbstsüchtigungsprogramm zu sein.
Ich finde das also,
es ist irgendwie so wie so ein man hat den Tatort gesehen und danach kommt halt dieses äh komplett dieses Ding wie so ein wie so ein Verkehrsunfall. Und du kannst du kannst sie den Blick nicht abwenden, ja?
Und dann fängst du an, irgendwann so nach paar Minuten fang dann fängt an der, der, der, äh, die Kommentiererei bei Twitter an. Und dass er auch, äh, diesen Sonntag eben der Fall gewesen,
Da war zu Gast, der der Hirnforscher Manfred Spitzer, der ein äh Buch geschrieben hat mit dem äh digitale Demenz und das ist wohl auch äh seit einiger Zeit ähm ganz gut ähm in den in den ähm in den Medien
und er schreibt da drin äh also ich habe das jetzt, glaube ich, das da mal so einen Klappentext oder so
beschreibt die digitale Demenz aus allen Teufelskreis aus Kontrollverlust fortschreitenden geistigen und körperlichen Verfall, sozialem Abstieg, vereinsamung, Stress und Depression,
Und das schränkt die Lebensqualität ein und führt zu einem um einige Jahre früheren Tod.
Ja, jetzt müsste man eigentlich Katrin passig anrufen und äh sie nochmal zur Rezitation ihres Vortrags über Technikfolgenabschätzungs äh Kritik ermuntern,
Ja, das ist halt so der Beitrag. Ich meine, ich wundere mich, dass der jetzt erst kommt. Es ist klingt so ein bisschen nach neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig, äh wenn du mich fragst, ne.
Ich also versuchen wir das mal. Ähm ich bin ja vom Fach,
Also versuchen wir uns mal kurz da so ein bisschen Gedanken zuzumachen. Was äh was ist.
Bist du denn?
Ich bin Psychologe.
So so.
Und habe äh mich auch mit äh mit bildgebenden Verfahren und solchen Scherzen äh auseinandergesetzt und Intelligenzforschung und solchen Dingen. Also was was er sagt, ist äh,
was wir früher einfach mit dem Kopf gemacht haben, macht jetzt eine Maschine und deswegen wird wird unser ähm
Gehirndumm, ja? Und äh verändert sich auch. Also er ist er ist immer derjenige, der sagt, wir können die Veränderung am Gehirn messen. Das ist so
Manfred Spitzer. Und was da immer so und das stimmt auch. Also was so Beispiele, klassische Beispiele, die dann alle immer zitieren, ist so,
Taxifahrer äh erfolgreiche Taxifahrer in New York, eine der eine der ersten ähm Studien uralt, die haben einen größeren Hippo-Campus. Nepocampus ist eine Hirnstruktur, die dabei gefordert wird,
wenn man ähm sage ich mal im Hirn eine eine Repräsentation von einer Landkarte macht.
Kannst du auch bei Ratten, Ratten trainierst du irgendwie stundenlang im äh äh oder wochenlang in in so ähm in äh in Labyrinthen, dann wachsen deren Hippokampi. Weil diese Hirnstruktur ähm notwendigerweise,
da sehr gefordert wird und deswegen wächst,
anderes klassisches Beispiel sind zum Beispiel äh Geiger. Ja, Geiger haben größere Cortex-Regionen, die ihre Hände abbilden, äh weil sie irgendwie mit den Händen da äh an dem Instrument rumfucht,
und ähm oder Gitarristen Pianisten, ja. Ähm Leute, die sehr viele Genauigkeit in den Händen brauchen, haben entsprechend
da größere äh ähm
Stärker repräsentierte ähm Regionen auf dem Coortex. Oder jemand, der äh zum Beispiel einen Finger verliert. Du hast dann auf dem Cortex die Repräsentation der der fünf äh Finger der der rechten Hand. Und wenn dann einer fehlt.
Dann eignen sich die benachbarten hier in der Region diese nicht mehr benötigten oder nicht mehr aktiven Teile des Hirnes an. Ist übrigens eine Hypothese, woher der Phantomschmerz kommt, den äh Menschen,
erfahren, wenn ähm nach Amputationen, ja, dass das eine Fehl äh Interpretation der äh,
ist die, die stattfindet, wenn der Rest des Hirnes anfängt, sich die nicht,
genutzten Regionen anzueignen. Und das ist äh genau das, was ich entgegensetzen würde. Also natürlich werden wir für bestimmte äh Aufgaben,
bestimmte immer mehr Aufgaben
werden einfach mit dem Computer gelöst, ja? Und ähm das ist ja auch schon das das Argument irgendwie, warum man Kindern in der Schule keine Taschenrechner äh geben will, weil dann verlernen die das Kopfrechnen, ja. Ist natürlich ein relativ ähm.
Also man sollte Kindern in der ersten Klasse natürlich keinen Taschenrechner geben. Aber ähm sage ich mal, wenn sie dann, wenn man möchte, dass sie Integralrechnungen äh machen oder dass sie,
sich mit Fragestellungen der Relativitätstheorie und Quantenphysik auseinandersetzen. Da war ich dann in den,
in der Schule schon ganz froh, dass ich einen Taschenrechner hatte, damit ich mich auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren könnte. Also mein Gegenargument an der Stelle wäre, ja, die Ressourcen
für ähm höhere Abstraktionsfordernde Aufgaben werden frei. Und wenn sie nicht genutzt werden,
und das Gehirn gar nicht mehr genutzt wird, dann verblöden wir, ja? Ist also auch, wenn wir uns die ganze Zeit vor Fernseher setzen oder so. Da würden theoretisch auch Ressourcen frei werden.
Nee, da werden echt keine Ressourcen frei. Das ist umgekehrt. Also äh bleiben wir bei dem Beispiel mit dem bleiben wir bei dem Beispiel mit dem Taschenrechner. Wenn wir Kindern ab der ersten Klasse in Taschenrechner geben würden
würde ihnen das mathematische Verständnis mangeln. Also was sagt jetzt ein nach vorne blickender hier? Forscher in Anbetracht dieser Befundlage. Wir müssen eigentlich anfangen den
Also mehr, mehr in Bildung äh äh investieren, aber das sagt sowieso jeder. Ähm,
und dafür sorgen, dass die, dass die Menschen es schaffen mit diesen Geräten, die in so viel abnehmen können, sich nicht darauf auszuruhen, sondern sie zu programmieren, kreativ zu nutzen und ähm
quasi dann äh sich dadurch ähm ermächtigen lassen durch durch diese durch diese Geräte. Ja, also,
programmieren, lernt äh die Nutzung von Programmen und äh schafft mit diesen Geräten etwas, ja? Und dann äh denke ich, dass das Gegenteil der Fall ist, als dass da Menschen mit Hilfe des Computers verdummen.
Er außerdem sagt ist, dass digitale Medien süchtig machen, also sie werden äh seelisch abhängig von von Facebook und Twitter,
Das würde ich auch sagen, das ist auch nicht wirklich überraschend, wenn die Personen irgendwie sich,
ihre sozialen Kontakte in in diese sozialen Netzwerke bewegen, ja? Man ist halt auch süchtig nach äh sozialem Kontakt
Und wenn wir unsere Welt dahin verlagern, dass wir irgendwie mehr zu Hause rumsitzen vor Rechnern oder mehr mit irgendwelchen Smartphones arbeiten ähm und darüber auch unsere sozialen
Beziehungen stattfinden, dann ist das nur normal, dass die, dass man davon, dass man da eine, dass es einen dort hinzieht.
Zum Beispiel, ich kenne das in Rechner ohne Internet. Also,
vor zehn Jahren, als oder vor, ja, vor zwölf Jahren oder so als ich noch keine Flatrate hatte, konnte ich mit dem Rechner ohne Internet etwas anfangen.
Und dann habe ich den irgendwann habe ich den dann eingewählt und dann wurde der verbunden mit dem Internet. Heutzutage geht das nicht mehr, weiß ich überhaupt nicht, was ich mit dem Rechner soll.
Ähm also das ist klar, das sind Bezugsgruppen, das sind soziale Beziehungen, die da stattfinden, ist relativ normal, dass man da eine seelische Abhängigkeit in Anführungszeichen,
entwickelt, dem Körper schaden, weil ja klar, wir sitzen,
in schlechten Positionen vor irgendwelchen Geräten. Aber die Entwicklung ist ja gerade dahin, dass wir irgendwie unsere Smartphones haben. Ich glaube, die äh schaden eher weniger dem Körper.
Dann sagt er noch irgendwas mit Nervenzellen sterben ab und nachwachsende Zellen überleben nicht. Das wäre also genau dieser Fall, was ich gerade angesprochen hatte, neuronale Plastizität. Ähm,
wenn wir unser Hirn nicht fordern, dann ist das tatsächlich der Fall, ja? Also der die entscheidende Gegenmaßnahme hier ist, dass man eben sein Hirn fordert und äh spannende
Dinge macht. Und was ansonsten noch erwähnt ist und da bin ich, muss ich leider sagen, da gebe ich wahrscheinlich so größtenteils recht,
dass die Lernfähigkeit und Konzentrationsfähigkeit so bei Kindern und Jugendlichen irgendwie ähm im Moment ähm Auffälligkeiten zeigt.
Und ähm das ist, glaube ich, echt ein Befund, den man ähm erstmal so, also die ganzen Befunde oder dieser Befund ist auf jeden Fall valide.
Und äh dass man so merkt, dass die Leute, dass wir mehr Lese-, Aufmerksamkeitsstörungen äh feststellen, ähm,
Schlafstörungen, Depressionen, okay, würde ich jetzt soweit nicht gehen, aber so, dass die Aufmerksamkeit sich verändert, ähm ist auf jeden Fall eine Tatsache. Und ist auch scheint immer schwieriger zu sein äh für.
Für Kinder irgendwie oder für für Jugendliche so sich längere Zeit mit mit einer Sache zu beschäftigen.
Das da würde ich ihm erstmal so Recht geben, dass das so ist. Die Frage ist.
Liegt das im Internet.
Ob das unbedingt am Internet liegt oder nicht an der gesamtgesellschaftlichen Entwicklung und ähm wenn es an der gesamtgesellschaftlichen Entwicklung liegt, ob das nicht eventuell wir einfach in einer Welt leben, in der man,
mit kürzeren Konzentrationsspannen in der kürzere Konzentration spannen eben den den evolutionären Vorteil bieten.
Also ich könnte mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen, dass diese hektischen Schrei äh äh Talkshows am Sonntagabend auch nicht ganz unerheblich dazu beitragen können. Auch wenn es vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt das ist, was die kleinen äh konsumieren, aber was der Geier.
Und ähm also bei diesem.
Meine Aufmerksamkeitsspanne ist auf jeden Fall wird dadurch sehr in Mitleidenschaft gezogen.
Solchen Sendungen. Ja, ja, meine auch, also wie gesagt, diese dieser Befund, der ist so da, wir wir haben eine Zunahme an solchen äh Problemen,
Aber das kann natürlich auch daran liegen, dass äh man äh die einfach grade im Moment äh den Trend hat, die die die niedriger niedrigerschwellig zu diagnostizieren. Ähm das heißt, hier ist keine, hier ist die,
keinerlei Kausalität nachgewiesen. Ja, das kann ich also auch mitm das kann das korreliert auch mit dem Klimawandel, ja? Der Klimawandel ist auch in den letzten zwanzig Jahren
irgendwie in die Gänge gekommen und das kann ich also auch kann ich also auch damit korrelieren, ja. Da ist also haben wir,
und wir haben keinerlei Ahnung
woran das liegt. Wie gesagt, kann einfach daran liegen, dass es gerade modern ist, äh solche Sachen zu diagnostizieren, ja? Also da ist keinerlei keinerlei Kausalität.
Nachgewiesen. So viel, so viel dazu. Und ansonsten ähm ja,
glaube ich, dass äh dass es, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer den Tweet gesetzt hat, aber irgendjemand twitterte ähm Internetmachdom. Sagen sie im Fernsehen, ähm ich glaube, viel mehr reden wir eigentlich zu dem Thema, auch nicht sagen, es.
Nee. Ja, es sei denn, man hört Podcasts, dann äh kann man das auch gleich wieder etwas kompensieren.
Da gehe ich mal von aus.
Ja, was ist denn sonst noch passiert? Äh das böse Internet hat wieder zugeschlagen und seine hässliche Fratze äh äh gezeigt.
Ja, das war irgendwie so ein, also ich muss sagen, diese Meldung habe ich so gar nicht so bis heute nicht so ganz verstanden, was das sollte. Also in Nonne ist hat eine.
Liste veröffentlicht.
Ja
Der ist der seine Buchstaben Zahlenkombination,
die jedes iOS-Device äh eindeutig,
kennzeichnet. Davon hat das Gerät sicherlich mehrere, nämlich auch noch eine MAC-Adresse und eine E-Mail. Die sollten auch ähm,
einzigartig sein und wahrscheinlich wird's aus einem von den beiden oder aus beiden zusammen wird wahrscheinlich irgendwie dieser generiert und.
Den kann man sich auch anzeigen lassen, steht dann in iTunes und das der definiert der der identifiziert quasi dieses iPhone als dieses iPhone. Und das wurde in alten iOS-Versionen zur Identifikation des Gerätes genutzt. Also.
Auch noch in der aktuellen, also ist ja iOS fünf äh aktuell und dort äh
gibt es nach wie vor die Möglichkeit für Applikationen das zu erfragen. Es ist allerdings seit einiger Zeit deprecated, das heißt Apple hat
kündigt, dass sie diese Funktionalität zurückziehen werden. Und es werden auch mittlerweile keine Applikationen mehr neu äh durch den Upstore gelassen, auch keine Updates, denen halt nachgewiesen werden kann und Apple kann das ja feststellen, dass sie diese Funktion
benutzen und sie wird höchstwahrscheinlich im nächsten Release auch schon wieder rausfliegen.
Ich dachte, es wäre schon äh wäre schon rausgeflogen. Also es gab damals den, das war so im Rahmen dieses ähm
Skandal ist, ne, wo es irgendwie diese soziale Netzwerk gab, äh was die Adressdaten abgeschnorchelt hat und dann waren auf war auf einmal das Thema User Privacy ganz groß und kurz darauf äh kündigte Apple dann an, so genau das ist der Prekaded und wir wollen nicht mehr, dass ihr das macht und äh,
ultimativ werden wir solche Apps dann irgendwann mal rausschmeißen.
Das äh ist auch einfach äh ist auch sinnvoll. Also.
Ja, ich glaube, für die Developarty das.
Temporären Identitäten äh äh gearbeitet werden, so für Sachen wie Push Motivations, also wenn ein Programm quasi einem äh einem iPhone, dessen Benutzer äh,
dass das mal wollte und erlaubt hat, äh eine Nachricht zuschicken müssen, so nach dem Motto hier äh ein Ereignis für dich liegt vor, ja, was weiß ich
Bundesliga, ein Tor ist gefallen, dann muss ja dieses Backend in der Lage sein, dein Telefon zu adressieren, eindeutig genau dieses eine. Und äh
Dafür gibt es dann aber eben also auch natürlich eine ID, die aber nicht identisch ist mit dieser ähm.
CF
Sondern die sozusagen nochmal eine andere ID ist, die eben für einen bestimmten Gültigkeitszeitraum auf dieses Telefon zeigt und die,
Backend sicherstellen muss, dass es sich auch immer wieder die aktuelle neue Version davon holt, äh die dann eben äh äh gilt, um auch weiterhin was dahin schicken zu können.
Genau. So, jetzt, jetzt hatten wir den.
Damit ist dann sozusagen kein Trekking möglich. Also das ist so eine Designentscheidung, äh die wurde halt da mal am Anfang äh äh getroffen. Jetzt sind halt diese Listen da aufgekommen. Es ist nichts,
also ich habe zumindest bisher noch nichts schlüssiges gehört, woher die wirklich gekommen sind.
Das Spannende, also diese Listen, so eine Liste konnte sich eben jeder kann sich theoretisch jeder erstellen, der so eine ähm iOS App hat.
Technisch betrachtet, genau, ja. Mittlerweile ist es sozusagen wenn es bekannt würde, würde das eben zur äh Entfernung dieser Software führen.
So und jetzt ähm kam Antisek, so eine äh Hackergruppe aus dem äh Northeims Kreis
und meinten, ja, wir haben irgendwie einen vom FBI gehackt und der hatte zwölf Millionen Judi-IDs auf seiner Festplatte und wir veröffentlichen jetzt hier schon mal eine Millionen davon.
Und,
haben also eigentlich es einfach mal so aufn Busch gehauen, ja? Und ähm jetzt ist halt die Frage, also das FBI sagte dann, äh ja, nee, äh ist nicht von uns, wir haben keine Ahnung, wovon ihr redet. Apple sagte, wir haben dem FBI keine äh UD IDs gegeben,
und Fefe schrieb dann noch, dass sie, äh, weil das FBI ähm,
viel, viel Argumentation war irgendwie so, weil das FBI ähm behauptet, dass sie nicht vom FBI sind, muss es ja vom FBI sein.
Klar.
So, wenn sie's leugnen, wenn sie's leugnen, dann muss es ja muss es wahr sein. Also, okay, also mal, keine Ahnung. Die Frage ist,
Ach so und dann gab's eine sehr schöne Geschichte, diesen Adrian von der wollte dann unbedingt mit Enormes irgendwie ein Interview führen und dann sagte, sagten sie ihm im im im IAC-Kanal ja, wir reden erst wieder mit Gorka
Wenn du ähm einen Tag lang auf der Startseite bist mit einem an und einem Schuh auf dem Kopf.
Woraufhin der dann einen Tag ähm auf der Gorka Startseite im äh also in so einem komischen rosa Kleid war und sich so einen großen äh Sportschuh auf dem Kopf gehalten.
Ja, also ich meine, größer kann man sich auch ja, Entschuldigung, ich habe, wenn im Tütü, ja.
Sehr hübsch. Warum wollten sie nicht mit ihm reden? Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Weil die den irgendwie nicht mehr mögen. Die mochten den schon länger nicht mehr, stand dann da, also irgendjemand irgendjemand dem äh Nonnen ist IRC,
oder mochte Adrian die äh die mögen die Gorke aber ohnehin nicht. Die haben die sowieso schon mal vor ein paar Jahren, haben die denen äh da die komplette Bude auseinander genommen, wenn ich mich äh korrekt entsinne.
Ähm also die, die verarschen dann noch irgendwie diesen Gorka und ehrlich gesagt kommt mir dieser Kram so ein bisschen vor, als würden die da äh alle möglichen Leute äh,
verarschen. Also dass dem FBI in die Schuhe schieben und was nicht alles äh mein die Frage, die für mich ungeklärt ist,
was was kann man mit dieser Liste anfangen? Also mir fällt nichts ein, was ich damit sollte. Also in diesem Fall
sind dann noch die Namen der die Benennung der iPads dabei, das ist nochmal ein bisschen mehr
Datenschutzverletzung sage ich mal, der der die Weißnahme, aber so wirklich weiß nicht, was ich mit dieser Liste so. Ich habe sie natürlich runtergeladen, aber ich weiß nicht, was ich damit soll.
Ja, also okay, wenn irgendjemand zwölf Millionen Judi-IDis gesammelt hat, dann oder sagen wir mal in dem Fall eine Million, dann muss eine sehr, entweder eine sehr erfolgreiche App gewesen sein.
Ähm aber also auch das FBI wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was die damit wollen würden. Ist mir irgendwie unklar. Vielleicht kann es das jemand in den Kommentaren mal ähm mal mitteilen.
Ja, also ich meine, so theoretisch kann man dann halt irgendwie auch über andere Datenbanken, die diese IDs äh gesammelt haben, dann halt irgendwas rauskriegen, aber äh was so der praktische Nutzen davon sein soll, erschließt sich mir ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht so richtig.
Apple im Titel und so und schon.
Apple, FBI und Enorm ist, Alter, da geht's rund.
Ja, also was allerdings sozusagen dieses Anonymus-Kollektiv jetzt so treibt generell, das erschließt sich mir auch in zunehmendem Maße äh nicht mehr so recht.
Ähm neben mir auch nicht so wirklich. Also wir werden mal sehen. Also aber was heißt auch dieses enormes Kollektiv? Lassen vielleicht äh gehen wir da jetzt erstmal nicht so.
Ja, also genau, also ich äh hatte vielleicht das nur noch so äh,
als Anhang schon als irgendwie jetzt was anderes äh äh passiert, weil sich wieder auch irgendjemand anderes als äh Anonymus ausgegeben hat, äh hier diese diese Didos-Attacke gegen äh Telecomics,
was auch so den Eindruck macht, als ob da sozusagen niemand dahinter steht, der sich der bis vor kurzem noch halbwegs als Anonymus hätte gelten dürfen, so, ja. Habe ich einfach nur festgestellt, ähm dass.
Einfach diese Marke, ja, dieses dieser einfach schon extrem äh äh verwässert ist, weil einfach alle,
und jeder irgendwie äh sich diese Marke auf die Stirn kleben und einfach,
sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig wird da noch irgendwas sinnvolles drunter zu unternehmen, weil man einfach davon ausgehen muss, dass es immer noch die entsprechende Anzahl Lonis gibt, die dann eben ihre bekloppte Aktion des Tages äh unter derselben Flagge segeln lassen, ne.
Ja, also das ist aber was anderes, musst du ja nicht äh was anderes steht ja nicht zu erwarten, ähm wenn du ein enormes machst, ja, wo wo jeder äh sagen kann, wir sind wir sind alle, wir sind dabei, ne,
insofern ja diese Dedosattacke auf Telekomics habe ich ohnehin nicht verstanden.
Und ähm also ich habe weder verstanden, was die sollte, noch warum man sich darüber ärgern sollte. Ähm also Dedos-Attacken auf die Gefahr, dass ich nicht wiederhole
vielleicht für die äh weniger genau wenn wir in Tech Team kommen, sollen wir immer den Hörern erklären, worum's geht, also eine Dedos-Attacke äh besteht darin, dass man ein ein Server
mit so vielen Anfragen oder so vielen Daten überflutet, dass dieser,
nicht mehr Herr wird und aufhört zu antworten. Ähm.
Das kann man auf verschiedene elegante Weisen machen ähm,
teilweise eben vielleicht auch durch durch elegantere Weisen, die dazu führen, dass der Rechner dann halt sehr viel CPU-Leistung verbraucht. Also, aber letztendlich äh passiert nichts, außer, dass die Kiste nicht mehr nicht mehr antwortet.
Na ja, es gibt einen äh interessanten Aspekt dabei, ne. Also durch,
den du dort äh erzeugst ähm.
Schaffst du Kosten.
Führt das dann in je nachdem wie die Tarifierung so ist dazu, dass einfach äh unglaubliche Traffickosten entstehen.
Hast du selber aber genauso.
Ja gut, aber wenn das jemand macht, der auf die Traffickosten scheißen kann oder der aus irgendwelchen Gründen einfach sehr viel mehr äh,
Ich meine, es sind ja viele, die auf einen gehen, ja? Und wenn wenn viele im Rahmen äh ihres Traffics, was sie sich leisten können, auf einen einschlagen,
dessen Traffic wiederum dadurch so hoch geht, dass äh dass das einfach alle Limits sprengt. Und das war in diesem Fall übrigens so, ja? Also das,
isch, große äh äh Beträge aufgelaufen wären, wären.
Wenn der Provider nicht.
Äh nicht gesagt. Hier äh macht euch keine Sorgen, ist alles prima, ne? Aber ansonsten hätte sich das äh locker im fünfstelligen Bereich bewegt.
Ja, ist mir alles bekannt. Äh, das war auch eine ganze Menge. Also, das war wenn ich, wenn man den Aussagen aus dem Umfeld von Telekom nichts glauben kann, waren das sieben Gigabit pro Server, die da reingeflogen sind. Also, das ist eine.
Ja, genau.
Unvorstellbar, ja? Also ähm das ist echt ja.
Also ich frage mich, wie die da überhaupt angekommen sein sollen, ja, also keine Ahnung. Also das war jetzt wurde mir da so so berichtet,
genau also es gibt diese Kostenfrage, du kannst aber auch einfach die Kiste ausmachen und dann hat sich das erledigt. Also ich verstehe nicht, was ähm der Reiz einer Dedosattacke sein soll. Verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Ja, ist schwierig zu ergründen.
Ist mir völlig, völlig, völlig, äh, völlig unklar, was das, was das soll. Ähm
hat also irgendwie stattgefunden und war auch wieder eine tolle Aktion, wo irgendjemand enormes dran geschrieben hat, wobei sich die Anzeichen verdichteten, dass das kein
typischer Enormesfall war, weil ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht, dass die auf sieben Gigabitisekunde kommen können
und ähm zweitens waren auch an dem Text irgendwelche äh Sachen etwas auffällig. Aber ist mir ehrlich gesagt also.
Weiß ich nicht, was was es soll und ähm,
wird immer unergründlicher, was was irgendwie bei äh Nornen bis so für Sachen stattfinden oder unter dem Label äh Nonne ist. Ich bin mir aber auch sicher, dass es da irgendwie noch einen einen aufrechten Kern gibt, die irgendwie,
viele auf dieses Label geben und denen das irgendwie sehr wichtig ist und die sich wahrscheinlich auch selber sehr ärgern, äh wenn durch so komische Aktionen ähm ihre
Identifikationsmarke da in den in den Dreck gezogen.
Absolut. Na ja. Bleiben wir bei den äh nitzpolitisch äh relevanteren äh äh Themenlagen. Also wurde mal wieder demonstriert ein bisschen, ne?
Ja, es wurde, äh es wurde demonstriert gegen die GEMA, ähm das war sehr äh sehr spannend,
ähm es geht jetzt, es gehen wieder um um unsere Clubs, ne, um die um die äh,
Gebühren ja erhöht werden sollen. Und als wir da vor einigen Folgen drüber gesprochen haben war das ja so
äh dass ich irgendwie ein bisschen
auch äh negativ oder berechtigende Kommentare bekommen habe, was also diese neue Tarifreform angeht und
Und es ist wirklich mein, man blickt da kaum noch durch. Also es geht um die Tarifreform der GEMA für die öffentliche Aufführung. Und die ist auf jeden Fall so und jetzt sagen wir mal, lassen sie mal den Faktor weg, dass es auf jeden Fall,
Betreiber sehr, sehr viel teurer wird. Ähm unabhängig äh davon ähm,
wie viel. Aber auch und auch auf jeden Fall signifikant teurer. Ich glaube, das sind das sind Dinge, auf die man sich einigen kann. Das bestätigt sogar äh die GEMA
und die Clubs haben natürlich dann jetzt mobilisiert und gesagt, hier äh äh draufhauen, ne? Und wir wollen jetzt eine Demo machen, da haben sie in Berlin und in Hamburg und in Frankfurt und und wo nicht überall.
Haben sie ihre Demos angekündigt und veranstaltet und die haben jetzt also am Donnerstag, glaube ich, äh stattgefunden. Donnerstag, den,
sechsten September und am Montag den dritten September ging also irgendwie eine eine E-Mail von GEMA-Information,
ähm an.
Gemer Minus Newsletter at XMR drei Punkt com. War da war die Absenderadresse. Und es ging wohl an ähm.
An an E-Mail an E-Mail an E-Mail-Adressen von Mitgliedern der GEMA,
und da drin wurde angekündigt liebe Mitglieder sicherlich haben sie mitbekommen, dass die Clubs irgendwie in Berlin, Dortmund, Dresden, Frankfurt, Leipzig, München, Nürnberg, Stuttgart demonstrieren können,
und ähm.
Das Hauptaktionsbündnis Kultur retten DE will uns hier irgendwie Ärger machen und wir müssen uns irgendwie dagegen wehren. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen.
Äh wir äh wir wehren uns dagegen. Und dann stand halt dieser schöne, dieser schöne Satz drin.
Wie agieren wir? Ein rechtliches Vorgehen der GEMA ist,
auch wenn wir vor den Organisatoren vielfach mit falschen und polemischen Behauptungen gearbeitet wird, aufgrund des grundsätzlich gewährleisteten Versammlungsrechts nicht möglich.
Ja, ja, geh mal. Schade, ne? Schade. Aber, ja, geh mal nicht geschlagen. Sie möchte,
Unser Ziel ist es, die Diskussion zu versachlichen, ja? Wir bereiten uns kommunikativ sowie medial darauf vor,
im Vorfeld über Interviews, Statements und lancierte Medienberichte und ein Schreiben an die Diskotheken und Clubbetreiber. Am Tag selbst
laden wir die Presse in allen Bezirksdirektionen und Generaldirektionen zu einem Gespräch rein. Die Dynamik in den Social Media Kanälen verfolgen wir mit einem erweiterten Backup-Team, das hier schnell und schlagkräftig Posts und Tweets
kommentiert, um die Diskussion rund um die Demo sachlich steuert.
Steuert, sehr schön.
Lancierte Medienberichte. Ich werde wahnsinnig, also.
Die Nerven liegen äh zunehmend lang, habe ich so den Eindruck, ne?
Dann schreiben sie,
da unsere Datenbank aktuell leider nur dreiunddreißigtausend E-Mail-Adressen umfasst, bitte ich sie, diese E-Mail und dieses an all jene weiterzuleiten, die diese Informationen womöglich nicht erreicht haben,
schrieb ähm.
Name steht da jetzt nicht, äh die Direktorin Marketing und die Leitung für Kommunikation für PR, der GEMA, der Generaldirektion aus München.
Und fand das dann jetzt auch auch statt.
An dreiunddreißigtausend E-Mail-Adressen haben sie das geschickt und äh ja wurde dann natürlich weitergeleitet, erreichte innerhalb kürzester Zeit irgendwie Piratenpartei letzte Politik. Netzpolitik, org, alle haben über diese äh äh über diese E-Mail berichtet.
Und dann standen die Demos statt, aber ähm erstaunlicherweise
fand diese Social Media Offensive der GEMA offensichtlich nicht statt. Denn es gab einen Artikel von Markus am nächsten Tag auf Netzpolitik org, wo gefragt wurde, wo war der Gamer Dialog während der Proteste? Äh Twitter null, Facebook, null.
Ja, also haben sie offensichtlich sich mit dieser an den kleinen Kreis von dreiunddreißigtausend I Personen geschickt, E-Mail, in der sie ihre PR-Strategie verraten haben, ähm offensichtlich jetzt auch wieder mal kein
großartigen Gefallen getan.
Teint. Und warst du auf einer der Demos? Ich bin äh rein zufällig in in Frankfurt eine reingelaufen. Es war so ein bisschen so.
Äh berichte mal.
Kleine war das so.
Ja, irgendwie in Berlin schrieb man auch davon. Ich war da ja nicht nur du reist, sondern auch ich ich war nicht in Deutschland und konnte daher äh keine GEMA-Demo äh besuchen.
Also diese E-Mail kann ich nur nochmal empfehlen, echt witzig. Äh kann sich dann, man kann nur mit dem Kopf schütteln,
Was ich dann noch gelesen habe an dem Tag, äh habe ich in der,
ich glaube, in der Süddeutsch müsste die Süddeutsche gewesen sein. Ähm gelesen haben sie so ein so ein Gamer äh äh so ein GEMA-Klinkenputzer mal einen Tag begleitet, ja. Und sind mit dem irgendwie ähm.
Sind mit dem irgendwie äh klingeln gegangen, ne und wo der dann so berichtete er dann so, dass also jemand, der in
äh Läden, äh Kneipen und so weiter reingeht und schnell irgendwie äh zur Decke schaut, ob der Lautsprecher hängen und äh dann irgendwie den Leuten den GEMA-Info, schreiben, da lässt, dass die CD-Player, die sie da haben, die müssen sie anmelden und so. Ähm
so einer. Und der ähm berichtete dann also,
Der sagte das natürlich die also selbst er gab zu, dass die Gebühren steigen, aber sie würden also nicht
so enorm steigen, wie man sich das, wie man sich das einbildet und hat dann da auch wieder argumentiert. Und dann hat er aber natürlich auch besorgte Anrufe von von seinen Schäfchen bekommen, die er da, von denen er das
Geld eintreibt und so war ein ganz interessanter Artikel, müsste man mal schauen, ob der vielleicht online ist,
Ja also es geht auf jeden Fall weiter und ähm ich sag mal zumindest sollte man.
So sehr ich natürlich gegen äh die also man sollte bei dieser Sache berücksichtigen, dass,
eventuell vielleicht die GEMA die Erhöhung dieser Gebühren nicht unbedingt so völlig daneben ist.
Tatsache, wie die Gamer sie nachher verteilt. Das ist nämlich das sehr viel größere Problem. Also wenn wenn dieses Geld tatsächlich bei den bei den Urhebern in einer gerechten ähm in einer gerechten Verteilung ankommen würde, wäre das sicherlich eine sehr sinnvolle
Angelegenheit, aber ähm da gab's einen Beitrag, den ich jetzt auch einmal verlinke, weil's ein sehr schöner Audiobeitrag, in dem
zum Beispiel die Erhebung der wie die GEMA erhebt, wie wie sie das Geld ausschüttet, erfasst wird. Und die haben irgendwie so ein paar Blackboxen in Deutschland verteilt, die pro Woche in irgendwelchen Clubs mal eine Stunde mitschneiden
und dann wird das von Hand abgehört von von,
von jungen Jugendlichen, die wissen, was das ist. Und die dann ähm quasi diese paar Stunden Musik, die die GEMA deutschlandweit pro Woche aufzeichnet, mal durchhören und dann entstehen daraus Listen.
Also und dann wird's irgendwie so quer verteilt. Also wie gesagt, die Erhöhung ist sicherlich nicht ganz so groß das Problem wie die internen Verteilungsstrukturen der GEMA selber und der Anteil an diesen Gebühren, die sie selber verzehrt.
Das ist sicherlich das sehr viel größere Problem, als die Erhöhung der Gebühren für die Clubs. Und man sollte sich da also,
zumindest ein bisschen skeptisch sein, wenn man merkt, dass wie was für ein großes Mobilisierungspotenzial diese Clubs da ähm erreichen können.
Ja, mehr wissen wir glaube ich nicht zu zu sagen, ne.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Also nur ich eine kurze Anekdote. Es gab in Berlin ähm oder es gibt ja in Berlin immer noch die Bewegung gegen die,
gegen den Umbau der der Ufer des Uferbereiches in in Friedrichshain und Kreuzberg das Spreeufers ja.
Mediaspray, media-Spree.
Media Spray, das Media Spree-Projekt äh will dort äh irgendwie ganz viele tolle fancy Sachen errichten und äh Hochhäuser und so weiter. Und da ging es um,
den Zugang zum Spreeufer und zwar war dann gab's ein Bürgerbegehren und so was dafür gekämpft hat, dass auch wenn da irgendwas bebaut wird irgendwie fünfzig Meter breiter Uferstreifen ähm allen Personen zur Verfügung
stehen muss, frei und so weiter. Und eine der Hauptmobilisierenden Gruppen oder Institutionen dagegen war die BA fünfundzwanzig ein Club am Spreeufer und das war bis zu der
Punkt. Und das war zu diesem Zeitpunkt die einzige Einrichtung auf diesem Streifen, die den Zugang zur Spree,
nicht allen zur Verfügung stellt, sondern gegen Gebühr von äh gegen Eintrittskosten von irgendwie zehn bis zwölf Euro,
das ist die einzige Wahren stimmt nicht, es gab auch zu dem Zeitpunkt auch gegenüber noch so 'n Club,
führte also zu diesem skurrilen Moment, dass sie dass die Ba fünfundzwanzig die Eintritt für Zugang zum Spreewufer nehmen äh unter dem Motto Spreeufer für alle irgendwie zu einer Demo aufruft. Insofern sollte man vielleicht auch die Clubs, die da mobilisieren, ein bisschen
skeptisch betrachten. Weil die natürlich auch kapitalistische Interessen haben und so weiter.
Alles klar, so viel so viel zu dem Thema, wir warten ab. Ähm und ich glaube, wir können jetzt zum Epilog kommen.
Ja, der Epilog äh was äh gilt es denn hier zu beleuchten? Also bei Netzpolitik org.
Scheinen ein wenig so ein Brainstorming-Modus eingesetzt zu haben.
Es gibt eine Umfrage.
Frage. Hm.
Äh wo quasi Feedback ähm eingefordert wird, um.
Die Plattform irgendwie besser zu machen und auch so ein bisschen die Fragestellung, wie man sich äh vielleicht auch künftig finanziell tragen soll.
Und ich glaube, es geht, also ich habe da ein bisschen an der Umfrage äh beteiligt, beziehungsweise habe da mein Feedback zu geben. Es geht auch so ein bisschen darum, überhaupt mal die Leserschaft kennenzulernen. Ja, sie sind so Fragen dann so, liest du Kommentare und so,
Wie alt bist du und so? Überhaupt mal so 'ne Idee zu haben wer liest überhaupt Netzpolitik Org,
ähm kann ich also nur drum bitten, da mal dran teilzunehmen. Ähm wird sicherlich helfen, dabei helfen,
die die Plattform vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen zielgruppengerechter äh aufzustellen oder so.
Ja, genau. Wir äh unterstützen das.
Und dann äh finden in der nächsten Woche in Berlin,
einige und wir machen ja eigentlich selten Veranstaltungshinweise, aber in diesem Fall mache ich das jetzt einfach mal
Es gibt die netzpolitische Sware zur europäischen Bürgerrechtsbewegung am vierzehnten neunten, ausgerichtet von den Grünen in der Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung, das müsste abends sein.
Und das ist im Anschluss an die Konferenz Netzregeln, die die Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung zusammen mit dem Bitcom ausrichtet am selbigen Tage
und diese Veranstaltung hat den Titel Transparenz und Vertrauen No Limits. Ja, also Bitcom,
der große deutsche Branchenverband in diesem Bereich zusammen mit den Heinrich Böll-Leuten äh und da hängen natürlich dann auch wieder ein paar
grüne Politiker mit drin, die sich dann mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen, sowohl die netzpolitische als auch die äh Netzregelnkonferenz
sind Veranstaltungen, die ich irgendwie eigentlich immer ganz gerne besuche, die echt immer ganz interessant sind.
Ebenso wie die am darauffolgenden Tag stattfindende Konferenznetz für alle, die die Partei, die Linke, zusammen mit der Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung ausrichtet.
Ähm da war ich,
letztes Jahr mal auch zu Gast bei der Konferenz als da ging's ums Thema ein bisschen drüber unterhalten mit Konstanze kurz und,
ähm Anne Roth. Und äh dieses Jahr wird hier aber an einem anderen Ort stattfinden und ich,
denke, dass auch das eine oder das das insgesamt äh sowohl der Freitag als auch der Samstag da äh für Netzpolitisch interessierte durchaus ähm.
Eine Reise zu diesen Orten oder zu den Streams, die sicherlich von beiden Veranstaltungen auch angeboten werden, wert sein dürfte.
Genau. Das ist ähm wiederum tagsüber, das geht um elf Uhr los und die andere Veranstaltung gegen ist halt die Suarie, also am Abend, neunzehn Uhr dreißig.
Das wäre jetzt der Freitag, genau. Und der Samstag, wann geht's am, das Netz für alle, am Samstag, am.
Um elf.
Ach so, warte mal. Und die ist aber doch am.
Neunzehn Uhr dreißig, vierzehnten September.
Genau, das ist aber ein Tag davor. Und die Netzregeln ist.
Und dann kann man gleich am nächsten Morgen weitermachen sozusagen. Also.
Genau, also man geht, man geht Netzregeln, Suare.
Nicht genug kriegen kann. Kann jetzt außer unserem Podcast sich auch noch hier als Dauergast äh auf diesen Veranstaltungen einklinken, zumindest wenn man in Berlin ist.
Genau oder wenn man nach Berlin reisen möchte.
Gut. Linus.
Damit wären wir beim beim Ende angelangt, glaube ich.
Werden wir, genau, heute müssen wir uns mal ein bisschen knapp machen. Ähm und äh ja, nächste Woche finden wir wieder einen Termin.
Nächste Woche finden wir ein schöner Unternehmen.
Genau. Wir sagen tschüss.
Auf Wiederhören.